[Music]
what is happening there reject nation
greg and john here today we're gonna
watch from uh our buddy paul heavy
spoilers here saw a few comments request
this i don't know how interested people
are in us reacting to this because you
know a lot of times you see a lot of
comments and you just assume that oh
this must be of heavy interest then you
do the video and you're like okay i
remember that
but we'll see you guys convince us the
batman cinemacon trailer footage
description leaks scene breakdowns and
comic easter eggs means the batman of
course looking forward to it i'm
expecting a new trailer this year's dc
fandom and i just want to say thank you
to paul on a personal level i talked to
this guy i think like every single day
and he really is just a gem of a human
being knowing him he's gonna watch this
video leave some sarcastic ass rude
comment you know because he just can't
take a public compliment for some reason
vulnerable
be vulnerable people accept the love say
you're crying in the comments or
something like that anyway let's see
what's in store
welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul aka batman and robbing
scoops from comicbook.com
[Laughter]
in case you don't know cinemacon is for
industry insiders only i really want to
go
and also have some great descriptions
from people that attended it right i
will of course be going through it all
but if you enjoy the video then please
throw your best batarang at that like
button and make sure you subscribe as
it's always going to be nice to see you
at the channel
now brandon davis of comicbook.com say
that the footage shown was mainly
through a feature red that kind of
talked about the movie and batman in
general love to see the one we saw at dc
fandom this had matt reeves opening it
up whilst describing what was going on
he said that his take on batman is
something that's dark and grungy and
this is something that the first trailer
definitely backed up true we of course
had the music throughout it being played
by nirvana a grunge band so they are
they are really going grungy with it
also did anyone else hear that
album never mind is also suing the band
for using his image no i didn't know
that kid would always be chasing the
dollar hey
wow that's uh that's surprising that's
so ridiculous
it's a very odd story especially because
that same guy did a recreation of that
photo shoot like a few years ago how
fascinating you know what's interesting
to me about this whole process is that a
lot of people have often been like
making fun of this we're going like oh
it's emo batman it's emo batman and then
for matt reeves to come out and say that
it's just going for a grunge vibe and
you're using a grunge song like okay i
guess it's evo batman
sequel he's gonna have like hair down to
his waist and like a goatee and he's
gonna just sing like chris cornell other
than exactly the same thing and just you
know they often are lumped in the same
category now footage then lit up the
screen and pattinson stated that batman
had been an iconic character that stood
as one of the major figures of the 20th
century lauren huff from entertainment
weekly said that when discussing the
part that he stated from the first
conversation i had with matt about it i
just knew there was something radically
different here we then got shots of him
in the suit removing the cowl with
reeves coming in to say that things
would be completely different to what's
come before reeves referenced the
seminal graphic novel yet won by frank
miller and said that this is batman in
its early days that's my favorite
compelling graphic novel
ew said that reeves described the
character as being very far from perfect
he very much wanted to enforce the point
that batman batman right from the
criminological experiment which is a
word that i've just learned now now what
it basically means is that bruce is
basically carrying this out to find out
if it's possible to have a symbol that
helps to change gotham for the better
films like joker showed how people's
minds and perceptions of what they live
in could be altered with a figure to
rally behind and the dark knight trilogy
was of course based on the idea that
batman could be a spearhead i like
hearing this so far because a lot of
people will say like the dark knight
returns or the killing joke is often
their favorite batman comic but for me
it's always been batman year one which
actually focused a lot more on
commissioner gordon who wasn't
commissioner than by that time and while
batman begins certainly borrows plot
points and elements from batman year one
it doesn't really borrow the tone or the
mood necessarily
frank millery no no no and and it's like
it's not as grungy as perhaps how matt
reeves has used those adjectives to
describe his film but yeah it's like
this is supposed to be year two of
batman but you know it's still like you
know not far off from here what yeah it
is a little bit more of an aggressive
batman so i'm excited to see that and it
actually gives me hope that it'll use
some of the plot points borrowed from
gordon in that comic and putting it over
here because you see him make some like
terrible mistakes
uh in his personal life so maybe they'll
do that to flesh him out even more here
unlike the dark knight trilogy reeves
said that bruce realizes that batman
isn't really having the effects that he
should criminals aren't running scared
and terror in fact escalates in the area
when murders start to happen which we
know are carried out by the riddler this
opens up a whole world of corruption
bruce is completely unaware of and it's
even possible that the waynes are tied
to it the trailer of course ended with a
riddler taunting bruce that he was
linked to it too and from what i've
heard on the film the wanes aren't the
way that they've been portrayed as in
the past you know hearing that gets me
really excited picking up at a point in
batman's journey early on where he has
been going at it but he's failing the
purpose of why he's doing what he is
doing is not leading to the kind of
outcome that he's hoping for of
inspiring fear and criminals and making
gotham a better place in fact it sounds
like it's starting off at a point where
it's just gotten even worse with him
around yeah incredibly human and
probably just letting his rage out more
than actually thinking of what's going
to make this whole city actually better
yeah that's actually getting more of a
rise out of him internally yeah that
it's like how do i produce different
results how can i be the best batman i
can yeah can i talk to tony robbins and
get a proper life coach on how to handle
this the twist of them being bad is
something that's appeared in a lot of
modern takes from the telltale games to
the joker according to what i've been
told they're gonna be shown as basically
politicians that starve the people of
gotham in order to line their pockets
bruce is what sets him on a path to
right the wrongs of the past
he must do better and change the legacy
that they left behind according to huff
reeve said it's a detective story that's
incredibly personal so this idea of the
waynes being involved does make a lot of
sense i do love that concept more of
exploring the dark deeds of the wayne
family i just think it makes bruce wayne
specifically a much more interesting
character where he's trying to right the
wrongs of his legacy's past you know
yeah that's just so much more compelling
like make up for the sins of the father
in a lot of ways yeah well that's a good
way to make it very relevant to things
that we discuss in the world today
without you know pissing people off by
going full-on
people will still say that i think
you're conscious but yeah this could be
an interesting way especially with how
many times we've seen the idyllic
version of you know what happened to his
parents yeah i mean what they're gonna
do is they're gonna you're gonna find
out that really it was martha wayne who
called all the shots
she had them both
wasn't thomas wade who was the hero it's
all about it
from what i've heard on people close to
the film the riddler will very much be
an outcast in gotham that has decided to
clean up the corruption within it and
this is why he's carrying out
high-profile murders on people like the
mayor and d.a this is something that we
saw in batman earth 1 volume 2 and the
riddler was sort of an anti-hero who was
committing crimes for the greater good
of gotham now over the top of this we
could catch batman mercilessly beating
people up in a dark prison set with a
shining red light over the top of it i
absolutely love this idea of batman
being very unhinged and from the first
look it seemed like the character was
very much obsessed with being in this
persona sure in prior batman movies
we've had a lot of balance between the
bruce wayne and batman personalities but
here it seems like he's just completely
focused on being the dark knight we have
seen something similar i love that
storyline but also in the new 52 run by
scott snyder both were filled with b-boy
pretty much casting bruce to the side so
that he could focus solely on being
batman however by the end of the work he
realized how important it was to have
balance so that people would stop asking
questions and also that he had a way to
infiltrate the gotham elite through
other means i feel like you just
predicted what probably the arc of bruce
wayne it is
realizing that could be an asset to me
that sounds like probably the journey
that is going on in this movie because
yeah i mean i'm sure a big part of that
is if he does feel like there's all
speculation obviously if he does feel
ashamed of the identity of the wanes to
a certain extent he could be using
batman as a way to hide from the reality
of being bruce wayne and here he has to
learn to accept that he is indeed bruce
wayne yeah and uh how to make a course
correction with the way name down the
path wayne named with dan dames okay
now it has been said that the film will
focus heavily on batman's mental health
and that it won't paint him out as some
amazing hero instead he will be
conflicted and though he's pretty much
you know a good guy from what i've been
told i'll also be a strong argument that
he's accomplished michael scarn cool of
course reflecting thank you here's the
famous villain the joker and his solo
movie i'm not saying yet before you
start yeah i'm not saying that arthur
fleck was a good guy quite the opposite
but he very much represented a person
that people could rally behind and in
that story at least he was painted out
as the hero of it even though the
argument exists that he's not okay look
i don't think this movie is gonna be
doing this whole like deep dive into
mental health and him seeing a
psychologist and all that stuff i'm sure
it'll be part of like the shades and the
nuance within the film itself but i
don't think it'll be as clinical in this
film however it is strange to me not the
context of what they're applying to this
movie what's strange to me is the fact
that this is the first time in my life i
actually got a little bit interested and
excited at the possibility of seeing
matt reeves batman and todd phillips's
joker actually interacting because i
think we go well damn if some of the
themes in terms of the exploration of
them are kind of on the same path it
would be pretty neat to see like oh they
really are two sides of the same coin
then yeah yeah and then finally get them
together in a room so they can mutually
[ __ ] about how terrible the
psychologists and psychiatrists
again i'm not saying arthur is a good
guy stop the hashtag heavy spoilers over
party now from here on we apparently got
several explosions police officers and
chaos spilling out into gotham pattinson
said he's really working out his rage
and that all the fights are personal
working out every fight is personal i
love hearing that people love hearing
weapons including pipes and he smashed
their heads in like you should smash
that like button go on oh do it give
your pipe stay up cinema con did drop an
exclusive look at alfred who davis
described as a classy looking gentleman
wearing a vest over his shirt they've
kept the bottle man sexier
and we still haven't seen him but
there's a couple of fan images out there
that could potentially show exactly what
he looks like he looks [ __ ] evil
though okay that he will have white hair
really i would love it if they just made
andy circus mocap again for no reason
we put a cg skin of a real old man over
him he's never given the opportunity to
play a real guy
nope that's his thing now from here the
attendees were shown some shots of the
batmobile driving and there were flames
coming out of the exhaust that was
pretty much all we got but i think it's
you know we can take a lot from this and
they're clearly trying to establish this
world that's very dark and gritty now
what i love about this is that they are
definitely hammering on the idea that
batman might be a psychopath he's going
to be totally is
absolutely
i love the biggest take that we've ever
had if you guys ever read any batman
comics dealing with the bad family the
guy's like such an emotionally abusive
guy like he's so mentally and
emotionally abusive yeah he's messed up
man he's a traumatized person who brings
that to the people he's a fascinating
character because he's been around for
decades and the more he he sticks around
the more you like break down like what
would he really be like
you know a debonair well-adjusted guy
yeah
rather than painting him out as a hero
we're gonna see the complexity of his
character and the mental struggles that
would come with being this kind of
person i'm super hyped for obviously and
it feels good to be back doing batman
stuff yeah i'm really hoping that the
movie doesn't get delayed and that come
the 4th of march 2022 that we can all go
to the cinema and see this film in its
full glory now i'd of course love to
hear your daughter
and what you want to see in the film of
course man i'm very very much excited
for this movie i mean if you guys
haven't seen our cheerleader reaction i
don't know what you're doing but you
should go watch it because i was
pleasantly surprised by how it felt like
the batman movie fan fiction thing that
i've wanted to see brought to life by a
major studio for so long and just the
more i hear about it the better it
sounds but guys uh thank you for
watching make sure to subscribe to heavy
spoilers subscribe to us hit that like
button more batman stuff that comes out
that intrigues us well of course check
it out thank you to everyone who
recommended this video hey we'll catch
you guys soon make sure to hit that like
button
[Music]